Given these technical trends, let's characterize the decisions that GPU designers have made.
One, GPUs have lots of simple compute units that together can perform a large amount of computation.
In general, the GPU is willing to trade off control for compute
and choose simpler control complexity and more compute power.
The consequence of this decision is that the GPU programming model,
the programmer's view of the machine, is perhaps more restrictive than the CPU's.
Two, GPUs have an explicitly parallel programming model.
When we write programs for this machine, we know that we have lots of processors,
and we have to program it in that way.
We don't pretend that it has one processor
and rely on a magic compiler chain to figure out how to map work onto many processors.
This programming model is a main focus of the class.
We'll talk a lot more about this.
And three, GPUs optimize for throughput, not latency.
They are willing to accept increased latency of any single individual computation
in exchange for more computation being performed per second.
Consequently, they're well suited for application domains where throughput is the most important metric.